- And one of the
things that the BBC,
the organizer said
at the beginning,
is that, you know, this
is about saving ourselves,
our economic models,
because we are, you know,
most people look
at us and they say,
"CNN and BBC are
competitors," but we aren't.
The real competition
is coming from
these thousands of emerging
alternative media sites
that are eroding trust
in the legacy sites,
and are taking away
our business model,
and we need to bond together.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is an environmental
lawyer, author,
and candidate for president
of the United States,
Robert F. Kennedy Jr., finally.
Welcome to "the Rubin Report."
- Dave, thanks for having me.
Sorry it took me so long.
- (laughing) No, I'm
glad to have you.
And with all the media stuff
you've been going through
over the last couple weeks,
you've given us
plenty to talk about.
First off, though, you
usually do these interviews
sitting in your library.
Am I getting the special
office interview,
or what's going on here?
- I'm in a hotel room
at New York City.
- Hotel in New
York, I'll take it.
All right, so
let's dive into it.
I thought before we get
into some of the specifics,
and all the media stuff
that's been happening
and everything else,
I was once a Democrat.
And when we talk
about you on my show,
people often ask,
"Dave, what makes RFK
a Democrat at this point?
This isn't 1960, 1970, 1980."
So I guess that's my
first question to you,
what sort of lines you up
with the modern Democrat
Party at this point?
- Well, I don't...
My loyalty and
affiliation and affinity
for the Democratic
Party is, you know,
for the party that
I grew up with.
And I think, you know,
what's happening in the
party today is unfortunate.
I do think the party,
I do believe the party
is redeemable, ultimately.
So, and I think our
country's redeemable,
and I think we need both
of those things to happen.
You know, if you went
through a checklist, Dave,
of all of the things that
my uncle, John Kennedy,
my father, Robert
Kennedy, believed in,
and Edward Kennedy believed in,
I would kind of check probably
every item on the list.
Whereas today, you
know, some of the issues
that the Democratic
Party has embraced
are things that I'm
uncomfortable with,
and I think a lot of people
around the country are.
And a lot of the traditional
base of the Democratic Party,
which was working people's
unions, American middle class,
and now more and
more minorities,
Blacks and Hispanics,
are moving away from
the Democratic Party,
because they feel like
they've been neglected,
and that the party
is not representing
(bell dinging)
their interests anymore,
or their values.
- What do you think the best way
to sort of separate
what I would consider
the old school classical
liberals, guys like you,
and your uncle, and your
father, from what's going on
with the more radical
progressive branch?
- Well, you know, I just talk,
I try not to talk
about, you know...
I try not to badmouth
anybody, you know.
I think there's been enough
of that in this country,
and people are done with it,
and we need to find a
path back to civility,
and to end this very,
very toxic polarization.
So I try not to, you know,
condemn other people,
and I just, I talk about the
things that I believe in,
which are the traditional
values of the Democratic Party.
I try to find, and
I've always done this,
try to identify the values
that we have in common,
rather than focusing on the
issues that hold us apart.
You know, I spent
35 years as kind of
one of the leading environmental
champions in this country,
but I was speaking regularly,
probably doing 60
big speeches a year,
to mainly Republican groups.
And I was getting standing
ovations in most of 'em,
because I didn't
focus on the issues,
like there's no such thing
as Republican children,
or Democratic children, we
all want a clean environment.
And yet it be had become
a very partisan issue.
So I tried to talk about
the environment in a way
that, you know, that every
American could embrace.
And I think most of
us, 80% of us agree
on 99% of the issues.
- Yeah, have you been
shocked at the way
the media's been treating you?
Because you've been out there,
basically talking to everybody,
having open conversations,
you're talking to
people on the right,
people on the left,
and the media has gone after
you in an absolutely crazy way.
I wanna read one
headline to you,
it's about your
wife, who I adore,
and we were sort of
in similar circles
when I lived in L.A.,
and I love "Curb,"
but this headline
that I'm sure you saw
from "The New York
Times," "Cheryl Hines,
the 'Curb Your
Enthusiasm' actress,
is beloved in Hollywood.
Now she's supporting the
presidential campaign
of her husband,
Robert F. Kennedy, Jr.
Is she normalizing his
often dangerous ideas?"
I actually retweeted
it, and I asked people
to come up with some of
your dangerous ideas,
and nobody seems to
really know what they are,
but that doesn't stop
"The New York Times."
- Yeah, and all of my
conspiracy theories,
as it turns out, have come true.
(Dave laughing)
They're no longer theories,
they're, you know, they're
now proven hypothesis.
But you know what, I
do wonder about it.
I, you know, I was thinking
about this this morning,
that because of this,
kind of this hailstorm
of negative publicity about
me, really kind of nodded,
it goes beyond like hit pieces
to be just this, you
know, poisonous vitriol.
And that is coming from
all the legacy media,
from "The Atlantic Monthly,"
from "New York Magazine,"
"New Yorker," from
"The Washington Post,"
from "The New York Times,"
from "Vanity Fair,"
"Daily Beast," "Daily
Coast," "Rolling Stone,"
and many, many others.
And they all kinda use
the same talking points,
and they also are not accurate.
You know, none of them has
really written an accurate,
and that's one of the
reasons it doesn't trouble me
is because it's
just inaccuracies,
distortions,
mischaracterizations.
But one of the things that
kind of occurred to me
is that there's something
bigger at play there
than just their kind
of hatred of me.
That this is, I feel like
I'm kind of on the spear tip
of a war between this
declining legacy media
and the evolving and
emerging new media,
the podcasters, the, you know,
all of these
alternative news sites.
And I'm in a
litigation right now
against an organization
called the TNI,
the Trusted News Initiative.
The Trusted News
Initiative was a conspiracy
that was initiated by BBC,
where they called together
all of the legacy news sites,
including "API," "The
Associated Press," "Reuters,"
the "UPI," "The Washington
Post," and many, many others.
And they married them to
the social media sites,
to Microsoft, to Google,
Facebook, Twitter.
And they all made an
agreement with each other
that they would censor
certain kinds of information.
For example, any
information about COVID
that departed from
government orthodoxies,
but also information
that challenged
any kind of political
orthodoxies,
like any reports on a
Hunter Biden's laptop,
reports about the Ukraine war
that were inconsistent with
the official U.S. positions.
And this was an
extraordinary thing,
this has never happened before.
But we have obtained
during the litigation,
the internal communications.
And one of the
things that the BBC,
the organizer said
at the beginning,
is that, you know, this
is about saving ourselves,
our economic models,
because we are,
you know, most people
look at us and they say,
"CNN and BBC are
competitors," but we aren't.
The real competition
is coming from
these thousands of emerging
alternative media sites
that are eroding trust
in the legacy sites,
and are taking away
our business model.
And we need to bond together.
And so the way it worked was
that they would all
identify issues,
and identify individuals
who were saying things
that should be censored.
They would notify each
other of those posts,
or those articles, and
of those individuals,
they would censor them.
And then the social media
sites would not allow those,
the sites that printed them on.
So if you were, you
know, green med info,
which is, you know,
a site that provides
wellness information,
or Joe Mercola, or
one of these sites,
these others, Breitbart, or
somebody who was departing
from government orthodoxies,
you would find yourself
banned on social media.
And those sites absolutely
require social media
for their business models.
So if you prevent
them from going viral,
the way their business model
works is they put in articles,
they print articles, or publish
articles that then go viral.
That's the only
way that they grow,
that they earn, you know,
that they can earn
advertising dollars.
So if you cut them off there,
and this is what the
memo from BBC said,
"We need to choke
off those sites."
So they wanted to
kill all those sites,
and they did it by agreeing
on a single narrative,
which was the official
government narrative,
and then censoring or
ridiculing, you know,
or throttling, or shadow banning
anybody who challenged
those orthodoxies.
So you have the, you
know, the legacy media,
which traditionally
was functioning
as guardians of the First
Amendment of free expression.
They were, you know, they
were supposed to courageously
speak truth to power,
maintain this posture of fear
and skepticism towards
big aggregations of power,
government corporations, and
they now become the opposite.
They become propagandas
for the powerful,
and oppressors of, you
know, of free speech,
and the enemies of
the First Amendment.
And that, you know, I
find myself, you know,
I now see myself as a spear
tip of this emerging media,
which is in an
economic competition,
but also kind of an ideological,
you know, Armageddon,
with the old media sites.
And, you know, so I'm being
championed by Russell Brand,
and by Joe Rogan, and by,
you know, Lex Fridman,
and all of these, you know,
kind of alternative media giants
in a battle, and I think
they see that as well.
Russell Brand said
to me something about
that the other day
that sent me thinking, you know,
about how they need
to, those sites,
really need to understand
where we all are in this,
where they are in this
world of, you know,
of disruption of the
old business model.
- Right, and it's really
bizarre because even now,
when they've been so frequently
exposed for the censorship,
your interview with my
friend Jordan Peterson,
from about two weeks ago,
was taken down on YouTube,
and then they put
it up on Rumble,
and now you're on Rumble, and
they're not censoring anybody.
But what do you think
about, so what would you do?
So if you were president
of the United States,
what would you do in
terms of big tech?
Is it breaking them up,
is it regulating them?
How do you connect that
to what you just described
with the legacy media,
that's offering, you know,
that's usually
pushing the pressure
on big tech to do these things?
And then of course, the
connections we now know
with the CIA, and FBI,
and everything else?
- Yeah, well, more
and more, you know,
we're beginning to understand
this, you know, this
judicial decision
this week by Judge
Doughty in, you know,
in the Missouri and Louisiana
Attorney General's cases.
I think really lays it out
that the social media sites
were kind of victims as
well, of the censorship,
because they were,
and I was, you know,
the decision is 155 pages,
and it's a decision that
forbids the Biden White House
from having any contact
with social media sites.
It's an extraordinary
injunction.
And it's, yeah, I
think it's bulletproof.
I think that's why he did this,
you know, 155-page decision,
'cause he wanted to
lay out the evidence.
And he talks about the history,
about how the Biden
administration initiated
this censorship push blitzkrieg.
And I was the first one
that they ordered censored.
Oh, the Biden administration
came into office
on January 21st, 2021.
On January 23rd, they
contacted Facebook,
the White House
and asked them to
start to remove me.
And then three weeks
later there was a battle.
The people in the White House
were threatening Facebook
with withdrawal of their
Section 230 immunity,
which is existential
threat to them.
Section 230, of course,
is the liability shield.
So that, you know,
if you defamed,
you know, Donald
Trump on Facebook,
and said something
that was untrue,
that you knew to be untrue,
that was (indistinct)
and very damaging,
he can sue you, but
he can't sue Facebook.
Facebook is supposed to
be a neutral platform,
and it cannot be sued, and
that's called Section 230.
Mark Zuckerberg said, "If we
lose that, it's existential,
we cease to exist," and so-
- Right, they would
actually have to censor
more in that case, because
they would have more liability.
So they'd be basically
censoring everybody.
- Well yeah, I mean, they
would need to read every,
they would have to have
lawyers read every single post,
and assess it for, you
know, for defamation.
There would be no way to do
it, it would just collapse.
So, and that's what the
White House was threatening,
"If you don't censor these guys,
we're gonna withdraw your
Section 230 immunity."
So the White House
was strong arming them
in the most powerful
way, to censor.
And then the White House invited
in all of these agencies,
the really weird agencies,
like the Census Bureau,
I mean the CIA was involved,
the FBI was involved,
the DHS, the Department of
Homeland Security was involved,
and also, like the IRS,
and the Census Bureau,
and a whole bunch of other
agencies were all involved
in identifying people that
needed to be censored.
And the things they were
censoring were really crazy.
You know, it was the same
thing that TNI was censoring,
like Hunter Biden's laptop,
you weren't allowed
to talk about that.
Anything to do with the Wuhan
Lab you couldn't talk about.
But also personal
attacks on the president.
There was a parody of the
president and his wife,
that they ordered taken down.
So this is, you know, really,
this is like King George III,
you know, back in
the revolution.
This is the reason we had
the revolution was that,
and put the First
Amendment in place,
so that the king or
the, you know, ruler
could not silence critics,
'cause if government
can silence his critics,
it has license for any atrocity.
- So what would your policy be?
Would it be that you break
up some of these companies,
or would it be that
you'd be regulating them,
or let them collapse?
- What I, first of
all, on day one,
I'm gonna issue executive order
forbidding any federal agency
from engaging in
censorship activities,
or recommendations, or
contacts with these companies
regarding posts that
they don't like.
There's, of course, things
that should be removed
from the internet, you know,
but it's unprotected speech.
You know, pedophilia,
and you know,
inciting violence, and you
know, those kinda things
you can censor without
violating the First Amendment,
'cause they're not,
they're fraudulent.
- Right, they're illegal.
- Yeah, they're illegal,
and they're not protected
by the First Amendment.
But otherwise, I'm
gonna order them all,
not only am I gonna order
them to stop censoring,
but I'm gonna basically
with, you know,
reinstate the Smith-Mundt Act,
which has been effectively
just forgotten about
and abandoned, that forbids
the federal agencies
from propagandizing
American people.
And that is just as frightening
what's happening now
with the, you know, active
propaganda by the CIA
through all of these
legitimate media sites
of our, you know, of debates
about the Ukraine war,
and about things that Americans
should not be
propagandized about.
You know, we should
know who, you know,
I think everybody should be
able to talk about these things,
but we should know
who it is talking.
We shouldn't have the
CIA running reporters,
and "Rolling Stone," and
"Daily Kos," and "Daily Beast,"
and telling us, you know,
pretending that they're
neutral reporters.
- How worried are you
that what Trump describes
as the swamp, or what
you're, you know, the CIA,
the three letter
agencies, the deep state,
all of this stuff,
that going against it,
and talking about it the
way you talk about it,
which is somewhat similar to
the way Trump talks about it,
that it's a machine
that is so embedded,
or as your uncle
used to talk about,
that secrecy cannot be a piece
of a flourishing democracy.
But it's so embedded in
everything right now,
all of our agencies,
all of our institutions,
ESG, all of these things,
that it actually can't
change that much.
It would, you know,
you can go in,
and you can do executive
actions and all that,
but somehow the system, the
swamp just keeps moving forward.
- Yeah, I don't believe that.
I, you know, I'm
very excited about
having an opportunity to fix it.
I've spent, and I think I'm
uniquely positioned to do that,
because I've spent 40
years suing these agencies,
and thinking about how do
you unravel agency capture.
And, you know, I've sued,
I've had suits involving almost
all of the major agencies,
NIH, CDC, FDA, HHS, and then
the Department of Agriculture,
'cause I spent 20 years
suing factory farms,
and you know, big
processed food producers.
And I saw how that agency
has been taken over
by industrial
agriculture, and you know,
has completely drifted
away from its mission
of protecting small
family farmers,
and providing America
wholesome food supply.
I'm involved now with
litigation that involves
the Department of
Transportation,
on, you know, I'm
representing 1,000 families
in the Norfolk Southern
spill that, you know,
upended their lives.
And that spill happened
because of agency capture,
in many of these
agency, I've, you know,
and of course probably 20% of
the 500 environmental cases
that I've been involved
with have been against EPA.
You know, which is captured
by the pesticide industry,
by the oil and coal industry.
When I sued Monsanto,
we came across emails,
secret emails that
Monsanto had exchanged
with the head of the
pesticide division,
a guy called Jess Rowland,
who was taking a
federal paycheck,
and supposedly working
for the taxpayer,
but secretly he was
working for Monsanto.
And this is the problem,
is that most of the people
who work at these agencies are
well intentioned individuals.
They're patriots, they're
good government employees,
good public servants.
But the people who tend
to rise to the top,
and become the division
heads, the branch heads,
and of course, you know,
the directors of
those departments
are people who are in the
tank with the industry.
And they, you
know, set the tone,
and they set the
agenda for the whole.
So I need to go in
there and do that.
You know, I've spent a lot
of my life studying the CIA,
because my family's 60-year
fist fight with that agency.
I know how my uncle was gonna
try to reorganize the agency
if he hadn't been killed.
I know exactly what my father
was gonna do with the agency.
In fact, he had a long
conversation with it
a week before he died,
with Pete Hamill,
who's my friend,
who's, you know,
is a reporter who
was covering him.
And I don't think it's
a hard thing to do.
You need to, you know,
you need to get rid of
the perverse incentives,
these financial entanglements
that the agencies have
with the industries
they're supposed to regulate.
You need to move around
certain individuals,
and then you need to put
in place really good laws
against revolving doors,
which is part of the problem.
You know, people
work for 20 years
for the federal government
for one of these agencies,
and as soon as
their pension fast,
they move over to the industry
that they've been regulating.
And so they want a good job,
and a lot of 'em are the
heads of departments now,
and they end up doing
a bunch of favors
for these companies
right before they leave.
And in order to
get the paybacks,
and I can give you example
after example of that,
but we need, you
know, right now,
they just have to
wait 12 months.
We need a five-year
wait to make sure
to get rid of those
revolving doors.
And, you know, but I
think it can be fixed.
Dave, I, you know,
I'm very confident
that's something I'm very,
very excited about doing.
And I'm gonna go to
the agencies myself.
I'm gonna go to Bethesda,
and I'm gonna go, you know,
to the EPA, and I'm
gonna, you know,
I'm gonna have direct
interactions with those agencies
and make sure that the end
of the State Department,
which is now run from
top to bottom by neocons,
who are, you know, job
is to keep us involved
in these constant wars.
And we need to move
those people out,
and, you know, and
reinstall the integrity
in those agencies and
the public purpose.
- So I sense you see
a bit of a connection
between, say, some of
the coverage that you get
in places like "The
New York Times,"
and your criticism of the
agencies and things like that.
Like you see this as sort
of one insidious web,
which I think is
deeply also connected
to the Democrat
Party these days.
I mean, the fact that you're
polling in some places
over 20% right now, and they
are making it very, very clear
that they're not gonna
put you on a debate stage,
I mean, a lot of Democrats I
think are not happy about this.
I know a lot of Republicans
are not happy about it,
and they're happy
to talk to you.
- Yeah, I mean, I, you know,
I think, you know, one
of the things I said
in my speech, my
announcement speech in Boston
is that the people who
are normally put in charge
of these agencies, and this
was what Trump did too,
you know, Trump came in and he
promised to drain the swamp.
And then, you know, he put me,
he named me as head of the
Vaccine Safety Commission,
and I started that
function, I met with Fauci,
I met with Collins,
and was putting together
that, you know, project.
And then when that news got out,
Pfizer gave a million dollar
contribution to Trump.
And Trump appointed to
Pfizer's handpicked candidates,
Alex Azar to run HHS.
And Scott Gottlieb, who was a
partner of Pfizer, to run FDA.
And you know, Gottlieb
came in there,
did an $88 billion gift
to Operation Warp Speed
for Pfizer, and then left
to join Pfizer board,
and collect his payoff.
So, you know, that is the swamp.
And, you know, people come
in wanting to change it,
but they get intimidated
by these big agencies,
and they, you know, get
frightened because yeah,
the agency can hurt you.
You know, if you go
after that agency,
there's a lot of top
level officials in there
who can commit all kinds
of civil disobediences
that will embarrass
the president.
And so what they do is they
appoint somebody who's safe,
they look at the
agency, they say,
"I'd like to change that,
but I got other agendas."
They leave the whole, you know,
instrument of corruption intact,
and they appoint
somebody who's safe.
And that person, you know,
Ralph Reed once said to me,
"The guys who get those jobs
are the guys who get
the joke, you know?"
- (laughing) Right, right.
- I said in my announcement
speeches, "I get the joke,
but I don't think it's funny."
You know?
- Right, exactly.
- And I'm not safe, no, I'm not.
You know, my job is to keep
the American people safe,
but I'm not gonna be
safe with the status quo.
I'm gonna be the worst
nightmare for the status quo.
- So for all the
people that hear you,
the independents,
the, what I would say
are the remaining sort
of old school liberals,
and for even some conservatives
who are open to a
lot of these ideas,
and a lot of the stuff
you're talking about,
it's sort of Trumpian
in a certain sense,
it's stuff that Tucker
Carlson talks about,
I wanna get to the
Ukraine war in a second.
But what's the way to
get you on that stage
so that there can be a debate
between you and Joe Biden?
Because to me, the
difference would be so stark
that that could
start the avalanche,
like that seems
to be the chance.
What can you do with the
Democrat party, in essence,
is what I'm asking?
- You know, I think
we need to go,
the Democratic
Party into a debate.
I mean, we're at a period
in history where, you know,
so many Americans
no longer believe
in the political process.
They think it's
rigged against them.
And, you know, the Democratic
Party and the Republican Party
oughta be doing their best
to showcase gold
standard elections.
And to tell, you know,
the American people,
"Democracy counts, your vote
counts, your opinion counts."
And we're actually gonna
do retail campaigning,
we're gonna have debates,
we're gonna, you know,
we're not gonna be
like the Soviet Union
where, you know,
where the party would pick
the candidate and tell you,
you know, "Here's
who you vote for,"
and there's no real contest
going on, and no real choice.
This is America.
We, you know, we model
democracy for the world.
We should have a
model, you know,
a role model election
in this country.
And, you know, let's,
you know, we need
to tell Joe Biden,
and, you know, to
embrace the ideals
that he stood for
for his whole career,
and not end his
career by, you know,
taring our country
with a rigged election.
The Democrat-
- Are you in any contact
with the Democrat Party?
I mean, have you, have
they specifically said,
"We're not gonna,"
I mean, I'm guessing
they don't pick up your
calls, (laughing) right?
- No, we're not in
contact with 'em.
I mean they've, you
know, been very clear
that they don't want
me in this election.
I hear it from people
all the time, you know,
"Why don't you, you know,
you could hurt Joe Biden,
you know, again, and
get Trump elected."
You know, people say
that to me a lot.
You know, people who
are in the party,
or, you know, I ran into
Hillary Clinton at a dinner
a couple of weeks ago,
and she said something like
that to me along those lines.
And, you know, and it's
strange because most,
I don't think anybody is happy
with the choices that Americans
are being given right now.
And I think, you know, we
need some other choices.
I'm glad Marianne
Williamson is in this race.
I hope Gavin Newsom
gets into it.
I think, you know,
we need choices.
We need, we can't just
have a kabuki theater,
you know, a democracy.
We need a real, you know,
we're supposed to be,
the Democrats are supposed to
be the party of the new deal,
not the party of the
rigged deal, and that's-
- I have to, my
audience will go crazy
if I don't say something
though about Gavin Newsom,
because he, to me, is exactly
why I'm no longer a Democrat.
The reason I literally fled
California because of him,
high taxes, endless
regulation, lockdowns,
keeping his winery open.
Like, so I'm with
you that you need
a diverse, broad
coalition of people,
and different ideas
and all that stuff.
But that guy, I just, yeah,
I would be remiss if
I did not say that.
- But I love that because
that's what I wanna run,
I wanna have that
discussion with him.
I wanna sit on a stage, and
say exactly what you just said,
because, you know,
we should have
the working people involved
in this debate, you know,
I want people who
I don't agree with.
And I also wanna
show that we can have
a civil discussion
with each other,
even though, you know,
well, you know,
even though we have
these profound
disagreements, you know,
there's nobody who
disagrees more with the way
that Gavin Newsom ran
the COVID operation.
And, you know, I was in
San Francisco this week,
and I spent like, I
guess almost nine months
in San Francisco during
the Monsanto trials.
So, you know, I got to
know the city really well,
and love the city.
And the courthouse is
near enough Union Square
that I could walk down to
Union Square every morning,
and you know, Union Square,
for people who don't
know San Francisco,
is like the Fifth
Avenue of San Francisco.
It's where all the
shops, you know,
Armani, and Nordstroms,
and Banana Republic,
and Gap, and all
of these, you know,
powerful, iconic
American corporations,
and the showcase of
American retail might
is right there, you know,
Levi's and all of the,
and it is Fifth Avenue West.
And I went down there
three weeks ago,
and every one of those shops
is closed, every one of 'em.
And it, you know, these
are huge buildings,
and giant malls, and retail,
and they're just closed.
They're boarded up
because they, you know,
they let them language
during these lockdowns
that just destroyed the city,
there's a 30 to
35% vacancy rate.
And there's no way
that they're, you know,
I don't even even
understand any conception
of how they can
bring that city back.
You know, you need
somebody, I don't know,
you need some very, very
powerful, dynamic character,
who can come in and
convince these retailers,
that you know, that the
policies are gonna change,
and that they can take
a risk on California,
on San Francisco again, and
that's all Gavin Newsom.
And I wanna talk
to him about that.
I wanna talk on a
stage, you know,
about what do you think
that's good for America?
You know, are you happy?
- What do you, yeah, what
do you make of the people
that now are refusing
to talk to you?
Because look, I'm with you.
I would love for you to have
that conversation with Newsom.
I think he's, I mean,
he destroyed San
Francisco as mayor,
as you're pointing out,
and then he destroyed
the state, in essence,
California as governor.
But you know, it's not just him.
I mean, you know, Jake
Tapper went on CNN,
what was it, about 10 days ago,
and said he would not
have you on the show
because of your
dangerous misinformation.
There was obviously this famous
thing with Dr. Peter Hotez
on, you know, telling Rogan
that he'll no
longer do the show,
and he won't even,
he won't debate you.
By the way, I then
had Bret Weinstein,
and Jay Bhattacharya
offer to debate Hotez.
He won't debate them either.
But this notion that
you're out there saying,
"Hey, I'll talk to you guys,"
and now they've framed you
as, "Oh, he's untouchable,"
as if something you've
said is so crazy.
- Yeah, I mean, if you can't
debate it, it's not science.
you know, the science is
rooted in reason and logic.
And, you know, scientists
are supposed to be able
to subject themselves
to the, you know,
to the furnace of debate,
and, you know, allow their
ideas to triumph in the mud,
to become a kneeled debate,
and then to triumph in rise
in the marketplace of ideas.
And if you can't do
that, I mean, they say,
well, because I'm a
fraud, and a quack,
and a charlatan, and
all the other, you know,
things that they say
about me that, you know,
you can't debate
somebody like that.
Well, that's a bunch of,
but first of all, you know,
I've won hundreds
and hundreds of cases
by arguing in front of juries.
And, you know, with people who,
if I was making these kind
of, you know, absurd claims,
and, you know, if I
was the kind of person
that was making those kinda
claims that were baseless,
that the other
attorneys in those cases
would chew me up
and spit me out,
and humiliate me in
front of the jury,
'cause that's what
we are trained to do.
And so, you know, Hotez
has told the truth
one time with Rogan,
two or three years ago,
Rogan said, "Why don't
you debate Bobby Kennedy?"
And he said, "Well, he's a
cunning lawyer, and you know,
I'm not trained with debate."
Well, you know,
every scientist is,
you look at what Darwin
did, and what, you know,
and even like Archimedes
and, you know, all of the,
Galileo and all these, they
had to defend their ideas.
I mean, there are forums
set up all over the world
where scientists get
together and, you know,
and debate each other.
And those debates are vicious.
And they're oh, for them
very, very high stakes debate.
And they use every trick,
but that's part of
being a scientist
is you take your ideas
and you give 'em.
And you know, the way that,
what I would do with Hotez
is I really have a lot
of domain knowledge
about vaccine studies.
You know, I've written
books about them,
I've assembled them.
And so I would, you
know, my way of debating
would be asking him,
showing him the studies,
and saying, you know,
"How can you explain this?
If what you're saying is
true, show me your study."
Either way, I've had
private debates with Hotez,
so I've probably
spent, I don't know,
10 or 20 hours with him,
because a few years
ago somebody asked me,
somebody who I was, with
whom I was very close,
told me they were gonna come out
publicly against me
with vaccination.
And this person is
very wired in at NIH,
and I said, "Before you do that,
put me in a room with the guy
who knows more about vaccines
than anybody in the world,
and you listen to
me debate them,
and then make up your
mind about whether or not
you wanna go public against me."
And so he called
Francis Collins,
and Francis Collins
and Tony Fauci,
and they didn't wanna
do it, but they said,
"The guy to do it
is Peter Hotez."
So he is their, you
know, their champion.
He's their Goliath.
And so Hotez did a series
of phone calls with me,
and this other individual,
and let me just say this,
the individual did not come
out publicly against me
after listening
to those debates.
But we then had a lot
of email exchanges,
where I would say,
"Show me the studies
that shows that
vaccines don't cause,
any of the vaccines given
the first six months of life,
don't cause autism."
He ended up sending me 11
studies about the MMR vaccine,
which does not fit
in that category.
And the Institute of Medicine,
the National Academy
of Sciences, those
studies don't exist.
I showed him those papers.
So, you know, I
don't think his fear
is that I would say something
that was sort of crazy
and detached from reality.
I think his fear is that
I would expose reality.
- Right, I mean,
that's the point.
Like, it's not like you're
some random kook on the street.
It's like if you were
saying crazy things,
he should be able
to debunk them.
Let's hit a couple other topics.
The affirmative action decision
came out a week or so ago
from the Supreme Court.
And you know, I've been on board
so much of what you're
saying, even though as I said,
I don't consider myself a
Democrat, I moved to Florida.
It's the first time I've ever
registered as a Republican
since I've been here in Florida.
But I saw your tweet thread
about the affirmative
action decision.
And basically you were
against the decision,
and I was hoping maybe you
could just walk us through
the philosophy there.
- Yeah, and I understand
why people, you know,
differ about that with me.
And a lot of the people
who have supported me
on other issues would
be disappointed by that.
But you know, that...
Listen, I grew up in a state
that was a Jim Crow state.
Oh, when I grew up in Virginia,
I, you know, it was
illegal at that time
for a Black man to
marry a white woman.
Every aspect of
life was governed by
considerations of race.
Well, you were
identified by Black
on your birth certificate,
you were raised in a
Black neighborhood,
you attended Black
segregated schools,
you transportation,
public parks, everything,
every aspect, you were
identified by race,
on your death certificate and
buried in a Black cemetery.
I had a guy, there was a guy
who worked for my family,
and I, from when I was
young, I was going hunting,
and trapping hawks down in
the southern part of Virginia.
And he would carry
me on those trips.
And he had been a
World War II vet.
He was in the Seabees,
he was six foot five,
incredibly smart.
And when we stopped
in restaurants,
I would have to go in and buy
the food and bring it out,
so that the two of us
could eat it in the car.
He asked me one day
to accompany him
into the local shoe store,
'cause he was not allowed
in the shoe store.
I had to buy the shoes for
him, bring 'em outside,
and he had to try
them on the curb.
Oh, you know, when
I, and then my family
was, you know, deeply involved
in the Civil Rights Movement,
and you know, a lot of people
look at affirmative action
and say, "Well, you
know, it's been 150 years
since the Civil War.
You know, people have had,
Black Americans have
had time to recover."
But, you know, I was, you know,
I saw that what it was like
to be Black when I was a kid.
I saw that, you know,
that all of those
higher levels of society
were forbidden, right,
you know, in my lifetime.
And my family was
deeply involved
in ending that
system of Jim Crow.
And part of, you
know, of that process
was doing something that
normally I wouldn't believe in,
which is allowing, you
know, considerations of race
to affect the judgments
about who gets these,
you know, positions in colleges.
But I also know, Dave, at
almost all of those colleges
already have a
system of preference,
and the system of
preferences for legacies,
you know, for people like me,
who had a grandfather
who went to Harvard,
a father went to Harvard,
uncles that went there,
and so it's much easier
for me to get in.
But all of those legacies and
also the offspring of faculty
are given preferences.
And if you look at a
pie chart for who's in,
almost none of those
kids are Black.
So this is kind of a way
of counterbalancing that.
And it's not, you
know, believe me,
I have a lot of
problems with it too.
And let me tell you
what the problems are
that I see with
affirmative action is one,
it's just contrary
to American values,
that, you know, that
were meritocracy.
It's an illusion
though, as I say,
that we're a meritocracy,
'cause there are all these
built-in biases and preferences.
But also I think
the bigger problem
is what Barack Obama called,
you know, the subtle
bigotry of low expectations,
that, you know, people,
a Black kid in a college,
in a good college, that people
are looking at that kid,
and saying, "Oh, he got in here
because he got a preference."
And I don't think that's
good for America either.
So I understand that, you know,
I think the Supreme
Court has made a decision
that debate is now over
about affirmative action.
We're moving on and we're
gonna, you know, try to preserve
the beachhead that
Black Americans got
during that period
in faculty positions,
in business
positions, et cetera.
But, you know, for
me, I would say
that we probably should
have kept it in place
for a few more years, but,
you know, it's over now.
- Right, I get the intentions.
Just one more on that,
what would you say in
that case to the kid,
the say 16 or
17-year-old Asian kid
who, you know, scored
perfect on his SATs,
and had all As, and, you know,
he knows he's not
getting into Harvard
because someone with
significantly less grades
is gonna get in.
No one gave that
Asian kid anything.
He might be second
American from South Korea,
and his parents owned a bodega,
that was a lot of kids
that I grew up around.
I mean, what do you
say to that kid?
I think that's what the nugget
really comes down to here.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
I think it's a, you know,
it's not an easy position
on any side to take,
but you know, as far
as that Asian kid goes,
there's kids getting
into that college
because they're good at sports,
who don't have that kind of
academic, you know, discipline,
or academic performance record.
So there's all kinds of biases
that get certain
people in and you know,
and it's not a merit, it's
not a straight meritocracy.
There's no college, there
are very few colleges
in this country, I'm
not gonna say no,
that just look at your GPA,
and your, you know,
and your test scores,
and say that the top,
you know, 3,000 kids
with the best test
scores in the country,
the kids are gonna
get into this college.
All the decisions are
dripping with bias
of one kind or another.
So, and unfortunately
the bias, you know,
these studies show
that the biases
tend to reflect the
racial composition
of the admissions department,
that they, you know,
people tend to favor
people who look like them,
and give them a preference.
And, you know, a lot of
the admissions departments
didn't have Black people in 'em.
And so, you know, it's not
an easy question, Dave.
It's not one that
I would, you know,
it's one that's inconsistent
with a lot of my other values
and ideas about the country.
But, you know, because
of my background,
and I, you know, I
land on that side.
- Yeah, I think that's as fair,
or as honest an answer
as you can give.
Personally, I
happen to disagree,
but that's just fine, that's
the point of all of this.
- Yeah.
- Let's hit a
couple other things.
So Ukraine war, there seems
to have been this odd flip
amongst the parties.
When I was growing up, again
as a Democrat in New York,
and my family, we all considered
ourselves JFK Democrats,
Daniel Patrick
Moynihan, Ed Koch,
probably many of the, you know,
people that you
literally grew up around,
but that were your
ideological heroes as well,
The Democrats were sort
of the anti-war party,
that was at least the notion,
and it was the Republicans
and the neocons
who then wanted to nation
build, and all of these things.
We seem to have
had a flip on that.
Now I get there are
plenty of Republicans
that are for this
Ukraine war as well,
but it does seem to
be being driven more
by the Democrat Party, at least
because Biden is in office.
What do we do?
Well, first off, I guess,
do you think that's
a fair estimation?
And then what do
we do about this
to get ourselves out of this
before World War II comes?
- Yeah, and it's getting
to a crazy point right now
where we're now, you know,
the Biden administration
a year ago said that when
they were called upon
to send cluster bombs to Israel,
the Biden administration,
Jen Psaki said
use of cluster bombs
was a war crime.
Yesterday President
Biden announced
that they're sending
cluster bombs to Russia.
And meanwhile they're
telling the American people
that we're winning the war.
Cluster bombs are a
last resort weapon.
And they're saying
they have to send 'em
because they've run
out of other weapons.
So what is actually happening?
Why are we being lied to?
Clearly we're being lied to.
But now you have this
split, and by the way,
the driving force behind
wars in this country
have been a group of
people called the neocons
that are embedded in
the State Department,
from the top to the bottom.
It's absolutely pervasive
in the State Department.
And they were, you
know, a lot of them
were driven out because
they, after the Iraq war,
they, you know, they
published their manifesto
in the late 1990s.
It was called "The Project
for a New American Century,"
and this outline their
plans for the world.
And what they said is that
America had won the Cold War,
and as the victor, it
was to be our privilege
to run the world for
at least a century.
It would be the
American Century Project
for a New American Century,
and that we should
accomplish this feat
through the use of our
superior military power,
and through violence.
And it outlined eight countries
that needed to be
overthrown, including Iraq.
And then shortly after
that, publication of that,
the neocons in the White House,
who surrounded President
George W. Bush, you know,
defrauded us into the Iraq War,
by saying there were
weapons of mass destruction,
and suggesting,
you know, falsely
that Saddam had something
to do with the 9/11 attack.
Now that war cost us in
the end about $8 trillion.
We left Iraq worse
than we found it.
We killed more Iraqis
than Saddam Hussein.
The country is now an
incoherent, you know, battle
between Shia and
Sunni death squads.
We pushed Iraq into a
proxy posture with Iran,
which is, you know, exactly
the foreign policy outcome
that we were trying
to avoid for 40 years.
We created ISIS, we drove two
million refugees into Europe,
which destabilize all
the nations in Europe
for, you know, the
next probably century.
I mean, what's happening
in France with the Iraq,
with the riots today
is a direct result
of our intervention
in Iraq and Syria.
Brexit, it was an outcome,
but was blow back from our
intervention in Iraq and Syria.
So we broke apart
Europe, you know,
and all of those neocons
were driven out of office,
and we thought they were
gone from government forever,
they were pariahs, you know,
they were living
in shame, disgrace.
And, but they reappeared first
in the Obama administration,
a few of 'em.
And then now they run
the Biden administration,
Victoria Nuland, Tony
Blinken, these are, you know,
key figures in the, in fact,
Victoria Nuland's husband,
Robert Kagan, was the author
of "Project for New
American Century,"
that document that
I referred to.
And they're the ones
who have, you know,
orchestrated this Ukraine war.
Their vision was that we should,
they've always wanted to
dismantle and Balkan-ize Russia,
and run Russia, and be able to
devour its natural resources,
you know, have U.S. companies,
and exporting the
oil, et cetera.
So they believed that
Russia was weak militarily,
and that Putin was weak.
They were mistaken.
And they said they felt
like if we punish Russia
with these draconian sanctions,
the economy would implode.
It would destabilize
the country.
They would overthrow Putin.
And whoever replaced Putin,
no matter if they were more
nationalists, more violent,
it wouldn't matter
because Putin himself
was the guy that was
holding Russia together.
And they had to get rid of him,
because then the whole
Russia, you know,
Russian enterprise
would fall apart.
And they, you know, they
say in Brzezinski's book,
et cetera, they say again
and again and again,
"We gotta draw
Russia into a war,
like we did in Afghanistan,
and expose its military,
and it's best to draw 'em
to a war against NATO.
And then we can deploy all
of NATO forces against them.
We can expose the weakness
of the Russian army,
and the Russian state.
It will, they'll be a
ousting of Putin, et cetera."
This was their plan.
So, you know, Putin did
not wanna go into Ukraine.
We now know that's clear.
He wanted to sign
the Minsk Accords.
Even when Donbas and Lugansk
voted to leave Ukraine,
he said no, they voted
90 to 10 to leave,
and he said, "No, you
stay part of Ukraine,
but let's make a deal to
protect you from, you know,
from the violence
of the government
that, you know, the U.S.
installed in Ukraine in 2014.
And let's keep NATO
in the Ukraine,"
which was the existential threat
that they were most
frightened about.
The U.S. kept saying,
"We're gonna put NATO
into the Ukraine.
We're gonna violate all of
our promises not to do that."
And then we torpedoed
the Minsk Accords.
France agreed to it,
Germany agreed to it.
Russia had agreed to it,
Zelenskyy ran in 2019
saying that anyone, 70%
vote, a comedian wins
with no political experience.
It's like, David, you ran for
president promising peace,
and because-
- God help us all.
- That you got elected, and
then you changed your mind.
Right, that's what happened.
Something changed his mind.
Clearly he was
threatened with murder
by nationalists,
ultra-nationalists
within the Ukrainian government,
and threatened with a
cutoff by Victoria Nuland,
the people, you know, the
neocons in the White House
and the State Department.
So then what we now know
is that April of 2022,
they signed a peace agreement
modeled on the Minsk Accords.
Putin signed it, and
Zelenskyy signed it.
And the Russians were
acting in good faith
by withdrawing all their
forces from the Ukraine.
What happens, we
send the White House,
and Boris Johnson over there,
to torpedo that agreement.
So we wanted this
war, and we wanted it
for something that had nothing
to do with the Ukraine.
Well now the neocons
are getting cold feet,
and there is division
within the neocons.
And Richard Haass, who's
one of the oldest neocons,
is now saying, you know,
Biden administration's
sending cluster bombs,
they're gonna try to
let Ukraine into NATO.
What's gonna happen then?
- Right, then we're bound.
- Then what will really
happen, Dave, is this,
we then have to, then
NATO is gonna throw Russia
outta the Ukraine,
including Crimea.
Russia will never leave,
that it would be like us
being defeated by Mexico.
It's not gonna happen.
You saw, I mean, you
remember what happened
to Stalingrad, the sacrifice
the Russians were willing
to make during World War II.
The Russians are unbeatable.
They're killing
Ukrainians right now
at a seven to one ratio.
We've killed 350,000 Ukrainians,
completely unnecessarily.
They're butchering,
we've turned that country
into an abattoir of death
for the flower of
Ukrainian youth.
And, but now if we
let them into NATO,
the defeat that
they've now suffered,
now all of NATO is
gonna go in there.
But here's what really
is gonna happen,
many of the NATO countries
are going to refuse.
Greece will never go
to war against Russia.
Many-
- Right,
it'll be us, in essence.
- What?
And what it will do is
it will expose Title 5,
which is the agreement
that where they all have,
and if one of 'em goes to war,
they all have to go to war.
It will expose that
as a paper tiger,
and all of NATO
then will fall apart
so that neocons in the
White House are now divided,
because some of 'em,
the smarter ones,
are terrified that this
will be the end of NATO.
And so they're now
saying, you know,
they're now telling
President Biden,
"You can't let
Ukraine into NATO."
And, you know, who knows
what he's gonna do,
because who knows how much
of these decision making
is actually taking place
in Joe Biden's brain,
and how much of it is
just being told to him,
you know, "Do this, do that."
And it's unclear because-
- I would say it's
probably very little
in Joe Biden's brain.
So let's just follow up on that,
and then I just have
one more for you,
and then we're good.
So what would you do?
I mean, how, so now
it's January 25,
what are you doing on day one
to make sure that this
thing doesn't escalate?
- I'm gonna negotiate
a peace with Putin.
You know, it's our
war, it's a proxy war
between the U.S. and Russia,
and I'll negotiate a peace.
And of course, the Ukrainians
will be part of that,
and, you know, but
let's negotiate a peace.
If Putin's wanted to
negotiate from the beginning,
we haven't talked
to the Russians for
at least six months.
Why are we talking
to them every day?
And by the way, you
know, these neocons,
like Richard Haass,
are secretly talking
to the Russian leadership,
'cause they wanna
get out of there now.
They understand that they
made a huge, huge mistake.
You know, by our own, you know,
we do polling over there,
the U.S. firms do polling,
and our government does polling,
and those polls are showing
an extraordinary
popularity by Putin.
Putin is now stronger than ever.
You know, he's got 90%
popularity and approval ratings
among the Russian people.
So, you know, they
have not weakened him,
they've strengthened him.
And the, you know, the
Russian people are resolved,
and they are not
gonna lose this war.
- I wanna ask you
just one other thing,
because you know, people
have heard you talk about
some of the reasons
you like Trump,
and some of the reasons
you dislike Trump,
and obviously
you've laid out here
some of your frustrations with
Biden and the Democrat Party.
But the one other guy that
seems to be in the mix here,
I don't know that I've
heard you talk about it
all actually, is DeSantis.
He's a huge reason
why I moved my family,
and two companies
here to Florida,
and I see what the results
of governing right are.
I see you guys sort
of lined up on COVID,
I see you kinda lined
up on the agencies,
certainly on the border.
I saw the video you
did at our, you know,
the wall in Mexico, just
watching hundreds of people,
from, as you said,
dozens of countries
just walk right through.
I'm wondering, do you see
any touch points there,
or, and what maybe
are the chasms there
that I'm not seeing?
- Well, I thought what
he did during COVID
was really, you know,
real leadership.
He broke with the
dominant theology,
and he did exactly what
a leader should do,
is he contacted the best
scientists in the world,
you know, the scientists
from Stanford,
from Harvard, from Oxford.
He flew them into Florida,
and had them sit down and say
what actually
should we be doing?
And, you know, he asked
the right questions.
And I think, you
know, Florida ended up
with a much better record
than any of the other states,
even though Florida has
this population, you know,
the most vulnerable population
because it has a, you know,
a lot of seniors,
disproportionate number
of seniors in Florida,
and yet they still did a
lot better than, you know,
a particularly comparable
state, size states,
like California, with
many fewer seniors.
And so I thought he did
really well in that.
I, you know, I don't know,
I feel like some of the stuff
that he's done since then
have have kind of
a mean side to it,
and which I don't like,
that it feels a little,
it feels like bullying,
but I don't know.
I mean, I, you
know, I've talked,
I've met with him twice,
and both of our meetings
were very, very friendly.
And I really, really
like his wife, Casey.
I think she's fantastic.
And so, you know, I guess
things to think about
and more to be seen.
- Robert, I will
leave you with this,
'cause I say it on the show
whenever we play your clips,
that if the Democrats will not
put you on that debate stage,
I don't know if it's too late,
but I have a feeling that
the Republicans would.
So either way, I wish
you a lot of luck,
and I thank you for
taking the time.
- Thanks, Dave, thanks
so much for having me.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of mindless drivel,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe, and
click the notification bell.